hidden figures uh which is just been
this uh
such a great i mean so many people
embracing this movie it's doing so well
and in the movie you're a nasa engineer
yes and were you interested at all in
space as a kid was that something that
is that comfortable i was actually i'm a
huge space nerd i was really obsessed
with mae jemison the first
african-american female to go to space
and she looked so much like me
and she looked like my family and i
thought wow if she can do this she looks
like me she came from humble beginnings
like me i can do this and so i've wanted
to go to space for a very long time i
was that kid who would ask my mom for
like a science kit i didn't really want
any you know
new shoes or anything i really did love
chemistry a lot would you go to morris
because now they're trying to find
people who would go to mars would that
ever interest you
you know i do want to go to space
but it can't be a one-way ticket like
the i'm very familiar with the mars one
initiative and if you go you can't come
back i need to have a round trip no
no we want you to have a round trip
there are people i'd like to send uh
me too
i'm sure we're probably on
yeah probably on the same page
afterwards
yeah
uh now is this true because you're
you're not afraid of much you're gonna
go skydiving soon i am i've been taking
lessons i posted like on my instagram
but i've been going to this place in
georgia and it is so amazing are you
into skydiving no what i answered that
so quickly uh because uh no i the whole
thing of
of that's what i'm afraid of so i'm
going to go towards it yeah that to me
goes against evolution uh
you know i mean you evolve as the person
you have to choose freedom over fear
right in all situations okay i'm afraid
of a guy stabbing me that doesn't mean i
run towards the stabbing guy no you're
right you're right no i avoid the
stabbing guy and falling through the
space falling through the air that just
no i don't want to do that and you know
me i'd be the one guy out of a million
that would do something wrong there'd be
a lot of video of it
it would go viral and my death would be
hilarious to so many people so no they
have especially you know trained uh
skydivers who go who go with you so
you're gonna go tandem you're gonna have
someone holding up yeah i'll be with
someone i'm not see the running towards
the person who's gonna stab you that's
stupid like no be smart go with somebody
you're gonna be very safe when you do it
very safe and i just feel like after
that i'll i'll feel like i can do i
always feel like i can do anything but
after skydiving i feel like i'll be able
to conquer a lot more oh good so it's
good mentally yeah let me know how it
goes i will and then um i still won't do
it
but i'm fascinated uh okay we're gonna
show a clip uh from hidden figures
before we do uh i was really impressed
with the fact that you wanted your
character
really understands loves math
understands these complex equations and
you wanted to really understand it i
mean obviously it would have been easy
to fake yeah but you wanted to kind of
understand what it is you were yes
talking about yes well um
i played an engineer the first african
female engineer her name was miss mary
jackson
and she was uh
you know
she had a lot of people saying you can't
do this you're a woman and you're black
and so she petitioned the courts and she
actually
went on to to become that engineer at
nasa and during that time these women
were doing equations that
when i was reading about them i'm like
wow their minds are so brilliant and i
wanted to know how their minds were
working and so one of the equations i
learned um it wasn't as intense of what
catherine johnson who helped send john
glenda's face was doing but it was the
um
elliptical equation and i learned about
apogee and perigee and what it means to
be closest to the earth and furthest
from the earth and what it means to get
an astronaut into low orbit you have to
if it's not like those equations are
done to make sure that you can enter
into earth and leave safely because if
you're off by like one decibel you're
gone yes one day you burn up here you
burn up on re-entertainment yeah yeah
you'll burn up on rio train you won't be
able to come back into earth and you'll
be locked out forever so that's very
cool that you wanted to uh i worked with
the mathematician
here uh no i work with a mathematician
in atlanta georgia and so i learned that
equation that's why i would not get that
role that was not mine
well two reasons why i wouldn't get that
role
three
three i think five there's five
[Laughter]
math not my strength